breaking news in the fight against the
coronavirus the federal government
approving the nation's first covit 19
vaccination
about 3 million doses of pfizer's
vaccine are expected to be shipped
this weekend the beginning of what will
be the largest vaccination effort in
american history
the food and drug administration's
emergency authorization
clears the way for frontline healthcare
workers and nursing home residents
to start getting the shots in the final
hours the white house had put pressure
on the fda to approve the vaccine
a move many called inappropriate
political pressure
in a video statement released last night
the president said the vaccine is safe
and effective
and called it a medical miracle these
vaccines are also
very safe american citizens participated
in clinical trials that were far
larger than normal and had no serious
side effects
the dedicated and independent experts at
the fda meticulously studied the results
of the trials
and it has now passed the gold standard
of safety the vaccine was developed in
nine months
recipients of the pfizer vaccine will
need a follow-up shot three weeks
later a second vaccine produced by drug
maker moderna could be approved next
week a third could be ready next month
tom hansen is at mount sinai hospital in
brooklyn new york one of thousands of
health care facilities anxiously
awaiting those first
shipments tom good morning good morning
dana well mount sinai says this location
is one of theirs that will be getting
the vaccine we're still awaiting details
on the exact distribution plan from
pfizer
but president trump says the first
vaccine will be administered within 24
hours
after a very trying 10 months for health
care workers
and the country well this is
our ticket out of this pandemic i
believe and
back to something normal that ticket dr
nick gilpin of michigan points to
is pfizer's vaccine the company's ceo
said late friday it plans to ship the
vaccine out
immediately i couldn't be prouder of my
fellow pfizer colleagues
and our partners at biotech their
historic science driven efforts
have delivered a vaccine with the
potential to help bring an
end to the most devastating pandemic in
a century
even before the approval was announced
indiana methodist
hospital staff took part in a dry run
drill to effectively
administer the vaccine for anyone that
carries an epipen that has a history of
anaphylaxis
reactions that they should hold off on
getting the vaccine
at this time for people with concerns dr
anthony fauci on msnbc
was quick to dispel them and i will get
the vaccine as soon as it is made
available to me
that i will do it publicly to let the
rest of the country know
that i'm confident about its safety and
about its efficacy
the u.s government has agreed to buy 100
million doses from pfizer by march
distribution of the vaccine will be a
military level
operation with both fedex and ups set to
use special low temperature
refrigeration
in trucks and planes to move the vaccine
fast
and hospitals including ochsner in new
orleans are prepared too
ochsner is ready both with the ultra
cold
freezers the regular freezers and extra
refrigerators so that we can stage this
across louisiana the vaccine arrives as
the virus
surges across the country the message
remains
be safe with colorado's governor urging
people there
to still mask up but we have today
a vaccine that's 50 to 75 percent
effective that's called a mask
so not of course as effective as as the
vaccine that goes in the arm
but can play a role in reducing your
odds of getting it by 50
but also when everyone wears masks it
reduces the immunity transmission
and now the visor vaccine is here and
two more are on the way
the next phase that you're likely to see
is touting the safety of the vaccines
last night the head of the cdc the
former head of the cdc rather dr richard
besser urged all americans to get the
vaccine when it's their turn
and of course we will eventually see
former presidents obama clinton and bush
get their shots as well jeff okay tom
thank you very much